What this means as far as the actual delivery of services is once again you
have self contained, self defined modular applications.
You can think of these as more or less vertical slices through the system.
That each service is capable of self contained that it
has all that it needs in order to provide that functionality to the user.
There's a definition for it, so that the remainder of the system and
the architecture can have a configuration that it understands. And it's modular,
okay? It obeys certain rules about interactions. In particular,
there's a use protocol use at the level of
the software architecture protocol describing, how the pieces work together.
The overall intent is to try to directly relate, the business needs of the user,
to functionality that's being provided. And typically this means that
as a developer, an architect, you're coming up with a suite of sub-services,
that together can be composed into. These user facing services. You publish
them, you located them in particular places and you can dynamically invoke them.